gavin newsom taking heed over the
hypocrisy once again that he lives his
life with the governor is on vacation in
montana one of the 22 states that
california has banned state funded
travel due to anti-lgbtq
policies joining me right now with his
reaction is dave rubin host of the
reuben report dave he says well it isn't
state travel but his security is
certainly state travel and symbolically
this looks terrible don't you think
of course but there's no level of
hypocrisy or us exposing his hypocrisy
that will shame this guy he's absolutely
shameless i mean look him going to
montana where he's banned state travel
this is the same guy who was literally
locking people in their houses literally
doing that during quarantine and
lockdown who was eating at perhaps the
most expensive restaurant in all of the
united states french laundry up there in
the sonoma area and dining with
lobbyists and i think their booze bill
was something around twenty thousand
dollars uh but the hypocrisy is one
thing it's what he's actually
done to the state in terms of crime and
homelessness and drugs and house prices
and taxes and all of that uh the fires
the fact that there's a water crisis
all of those things
and somehow this guy dare show his face
maybe he knows he can't show his face in
cali anymore so he's going to montana
where people won't recognize him and
remember what he did at the laker game
everybody else wearing masks he's at the
luxury boxes with celebrities taking
pictures without mass watching the game
in a box without a mask his kids go to
private school while all the public
schools are shut down everybody is
zooming in and the people that need the
education the most but this guy doesn't
realize he almost lost his job to
embarrassing recall and now he thinks
he's front and center to be the
democratic nominee what i think is
ingenious on his part
but it is that he wants to take the most
popular successful governor in the
country arguably ron desantis and he's
actually trolling him saying if you want
freedom come to california where
actually florida is as free as it gets
is why they got so many people from
california i think 60
000. yeah well look brian you know the
book 1984 george orwell's dystopian
future newspeak that words will
basically have no meaning everything
will be opposite of reality the idea
that democrats but particularly gavin
newsom are talking about freedom and
liberty
you know as you know brian i fled
california about seven months ago
because of all the reasons that we've
just discussed i now live in free
florida which is flourishing absolutely
flourishing florida is actually blowing
up in a good sense in a metaphorical
sense while california is imploding in a
literal sense i mean just go wander
around the streets of san francisco or
los angeles or anywhere else so the he's
you're right he's trolling
ron desantis but i don't think ron
desantis will fall for it but what gavin
newsom really is doing here is is
progressive politics 101. you become the
mayor of san francisco which is what he
was he destroyed that city but you fell
up in progressive politics so then he
became the governor of california he's
failing up and this is clearly all his
move to run for president in 2024
because the democrats are done with
biden and they will have to go with
someone more more radical because that's
the direction of the party the 1960s sam
hough uh created a rivalry he said he's
the only one that could stop jim brown
the running back of course he couldn't
but everyone thought jim brown the best
running back ever the athlete of the
century they thought of sam huff because
he made himself made up this fictional
rivalry these two had redskins and
browns that's what i think gavin
newsom's doing he's trying to take jim
brown which is governor desantis and
he's trying to be sam huff we'll see if
the american people will buy it or not
dave would you think of my analogy
i think it's a solid analogy and look
man the proof's in the pudding which way
are people moving they're all moving
east california for the last two years i
know has lost hundreds of thousands of
people no one's leaving florida i assure
you i understand that um 25 minutes
after the hour dave rubin thanks so much
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell